now I want to know where possible
turning point arc tell you points
because I want to max in them so i will
say awesome all turning points well wait
what where the derivative is 0 right we
r DV over the equals 0 okay please I've
said enough times do not just go right
the next line as blah blah blah blah
equal 0 okay for what reason okay
because you're doing something you're
looking for something okay so therefore
pie edge o is to R square 0 now you can
see the clear advantage of have you
brought that constant at the front you
can pretty much ignore him up I don't
have to like a divide through by our
capital R because our is not 0 right cuz
it's a natural link that look good so
far checking out okay so from there I'm
just going to make a statement what is
the actual value of capital R that I'm
suspecting is where my journey pointers
it looks to me yeah like I'm going to
say 3 r equals to off right three big R
equals to the door so therefore big R is
just a 2 3 that's where I think there's
a turning point so I'm going to find out
I need to find out the nature of this
thing right haven't been told determine
the nature but I do need to determine
the nature I don't want a minimum do I I
have no reason to think it's a maneuver
because you remember those different
cylinders that I drew before they look
like those look like the minimums to me
okay but I need to test it for sure I've
got some different methods for using
this what should I use i think i'm going
to go second derivative right why is
second derivative a smart place to go
for this particular yeah this is look at
that right it's the first derivative is
really easy to differentiate right
here's the second derivative unit goes
right I've got that pie agent on our out
the front which they just closed this
took
me and then in here what do I guess yeah
I get to the jaw take away my six
capital a burger so there's my second
derivative and I have an actual value to
test right so when the radius I'm after
is two are on three okay the second
derivative is yeah I've got my PI H on
are at the front too ah that's still the
cluster take away what six yeah it looks
like horror on right because it's going
to be 12 are on three witches ah ok so
this is actually minus our cabin are uh
no don't lower case this is something I
stop did it they're all in capital has
gone down yeah okay so now this is just
a constant okay that's going to cancel
and cancel and cancer so it looks like i
get minus 2 pi h okay now i'm not
finished yet i haven't drawn a
conclusion yet what was it doing the
secondary for concave that it's gone
concave down yeah good i need to know
the sign of this thing's own eyes okay
sup so this right this is the second
review right but i know that h is a
positive number because it's a height
okay to like yet that's right so see
it's since it's positive right since the
highest positive then when you multiply
a positive by a negative number it's
negative yeah differentially you're
differentiating other specialties oh
well oh yeah so therefore i've got my
second derivative which is negative
which is concave down please don't skip
that step about saying concavity the
concavity is why I know it's a relative
maximum right
please do not jump to saying that it's a
relative maximum after making a
statement about the side of the second
derivative the sign of the second
derivative tells you about concavity and
the concavity tells you about whether
it's a matter or immune does that make
sense that's like a really uh yeah
because I don't know it's absolutely now
in this case you can see if I were like
testing and points is trivial because
it's like I'll let me test you can let
me test one whether what are the
boundaries by the way like the radius
which is what I'm working with it could
be zero I came to volume or it could be
the radius of apparent in which case it
has no height so therefore also zero so
I don't need to worry about that all
right I've found a maximum right so
pretty much I've done all the hard work
that's the radius that gives me the
maximum i want what was the actual
question so suck that back in to find
out yeah good I'm here right here is my
function of is my volume as a function
of that capital all right so i could say
therefore the maximum volume is V equals
PI uh whoops under excuse me I'm going
to use this one here pi h or are are
times what's i squared it with for r
squared on right okay with that take
away 8 r squared on 27 cute of course it
is okay dudes everything else except vr
okay good that looks good let's tidy up
a little bit i'll lose this R this R and
battle become square you quit with that
it's all over all the comments are over
now because i'm going to choose is 27 so
this needs to multiply by three so I'm
about pi h x 12 r squared take away 8 r
squared all over 27 you can turn with
that does that look good so for r
squared x
edge on 27 and don't forget you are a
little H I just numbers so I've done now
let me now read for you because that was
hard i deliberately made this question
harder than was before just so you could
do the mental effort for it okay let me
read for you the actual questions that
made out of part so you can see how
someone walk you through part 1 says use
similar triangles to show this they
actually give you that resolve they're
trying to get you in the right direction
now if you don't see that you can still
use it in part 2 which I'm about it okay
so there's the first part they tell you
you need two similar triangles and you
need to eliminate a variable they didn't
even tell you they're eliminating
variable if that's what you're doing
them okay part two is find the volume as
an expression in terms of the radius
right in terms of a variable capital R
so there's a second set and then the
third step is okay what they actually
tell you is find the maximum volume so
you know how to differentiate you've
already candid been handed ok this is
the void in terms of one variable so off
you go so I forced you to make a series
of decisions that the question itself as
it was originally presented it makes
those decisions for you but the
decisions of the high part which is why
I wanted you to think about it and if I
wanted to make an easy question harder I
would just take away the scaffold all
right and I can say all right here's
your end what can you get there doing
the way to get there more likely you'll
see a question like this one two three
but that's the easier case right and you
guys know where enough we talked through
it and you guys told me every step of
the way you can go from A to Z without
you know too much difficulty any
questions
now what's created at the question for
the reason why I picked it up or there's
to the reasons number one it was also
hard because everything's like gross
there's no simplification of any numbers
right because you're just dealing with
little Arthur H all the way through so
you just have to carry them that's hard
it just makes the algebra hot ok that's
the first thing the second thing is
though see these one two three steps
then the same every time I mean I was
talking about steps before and saying oh
you know you can't just memorized apps
but if you wanted to think about it
there is a general pattern it's the what
we talked about up here right you've got
to get rid of the variable you've got to
get whatever you try to maximize or
minimize in terms of that variable and
then you want to differentiate and find
your max or min ok it's worth saying
that if I had if we chosen poorly just
watch what would happen I could make
this statement here right and it's ok
i'm going to try and eliminate out the
capital R watch what happens right so
I'm going to get looks to me like um ah
H on H equals our votes are right so
then I get let's add him over here and
subtract him over there so I can take
out that on this page 0 h ok so there's
the capital R that I can get rid of and
I'm going to put that that uh yeah right
like look look at how far this will in
the actual variable you try to
differentiate with respect to is into
the function and right so it's yeah
that's right what's your square it's
even worse ok so therefore you could
have gone there but just all of this
would have been harder ok so that's how
you can kind of know all right even if
you make a poor choice just go back just
go back you look at this in your life no
thanks you come back here you get
watching sugars easy now like ok
that's true yeah well then prove my skin
my trying to look after actually ok so
this very much depends on and this is a
perfect example or like look at how much
where is the where's the emphasis in
this question what is it assessing right
and it's assessing these 123 exact
things that I've mentioned right in fact
this would be pretty much a four-month
question 1 mark two marks three months
of differentiating at fighting the max
and then the fourth mark is on the
action volume ok um does the similar
triangles rate a mark yeah it's that
it's the one that motion you gave it to
you yeah you similar time if they say
use similar triangles right like what
they're looking for you is to get this
ok I can I get that result if I see
someone get this then I'm going to give
them a big thumbs up us but especially
because I haven't given you like hey
peace I haven't called this anything
like you don't have like all i'm going
to say triangle this this this triangle
that that that and the angle so you
don't have your not been equipped to
talk about that which is one of the
clues that you don't need to worry about
it now if you want to be super rigorous
after you finish this question with all
that spare time you have in the exam
then come back and if you really want to
write ursuline trying was proof in here
there's nothing stopping you